[Music]
in Wyoming we tend to have soils that
are lacking in organic matter and one of
the best things you can do before you
begin to prep a garden site is to have a
soil test done and that will tell you
the amount of organic matter you have in
your soil as well as the nutrients you
do have and things that you might need
to add to that soil so some of the
different organic matters that you might
use are composted kitchen scraps and
yard waste from your own garden and yard
um compost that you can get from the
garden
centers composted manure that you can
buy in packages Pete Moss straw anything
that was plant-based before it became a
product that you'd use for a soil
amendment in the garden that will help
with drainage for heavy clay soils um
and holding on to water in sandier soils
so that you get the benefit of the
nutrient that you add to the soil rather
than having it drain away
when you put on organic matter um we
would recommend that you put on about 2
in and then rake it into your soil and
then roota till it in as deeply as you
can if you're lacking in nutrients you
can get a variety of different
fertilizers to add to your soil and then
your garden is really prepared and ready
to use for your gardening season this
will benefit your garden from the ground
up this has been Donna Quinn for the
University of Wyoming extension
[Music]